hey theo this is brayden from denver
colorado hey
braden and i got a little nephew named
braden who lives over there in um
spanish fork in uh
alabama let's hear more um with all the
negativity that's been going on
in the news and the pandemic i just
wanted to
let you know about something positive
that came about
my childhood friends back in middle
school and high school
we're all over the country and not for
us to get together but
because of all the extra time
everybody's gotten everybody working
remotely
we have set up a dungeons and dragons
campaign
that meets up uh once a week
so every thursday we get together and we
hunt dragons and do all sorts of fun
stuff together and uh
look i think oh man
i don't even know how to get into this i
think it's beautiful you guys are
getting together man do i think the
dungeons and dragons
always never really didn't know how to
handle that vibe
you know you'd always be you'd see
people meeting up in the back of a quiz
nose or something at night
and some guy's got a purple beard and
he's got you know his ladies got them
big
big big beefy tits you know them big
freaking them slush guppies dog them but
just damn like a damn
just big ol tits you know
kind of tits you hear somebody rev a
truck when you see them just
right when you see them like damn
you know that titties got octane you
know just you feel that titty
a little you see that t you know like uh
the kind of breast is so big it could
tell you're looking at it
so you look the other way out of sheer
just embarrassment or you know
mild shame but men meeting up to play
dungeons and dragons at night man i'll
tell you this i remember when i was in
junior high
and i was good in junior high and
and i saw they had some kids playing it
outside one day
and you'd see every you know one of the
kids looked like rapunzel and it was a
boy
you know and he'd have his hair braided
into a
you know into the other kid was wearing
his hair braid as a damn scarf and they
were all it was just wild [ __ ]
you'd have some guy would have his nose
his septum pierced then he'd have a
spare key hanging off it
you know to get into school and all of
them hated gym class these were the kids
who did not like gym class and i saw
uh a big goal we didn't get a lot of
goals
you know seagulls pelicans we didn't get
a lot of them
flying over campus when i was in junior
high but every now and then
the winds would switch over there over
the um
poncho train and a pelican would come
come by and i saw a pelican defecate
onto a damn uh
dungeons and dragons game
and i that [ __ ] made me feel good man
honestly when it happened
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you could watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one